this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development before we begin I'd like to
take an opportunity to introduce a few
of our speakers Carissa little is the
director for professional programs at
the Stanford center for professional
development and I would also like to
introduce bill Burnett
Thank You Stacey
I'm just want to welcome everyone to
today's webinar and let everyone know
that we have a bill Burnett here who is
the executive director of the Stanford
design program and he's also the
academic director for the innovation
mastery series which we'll hear more
about later today and I'd like to turn
over to Bill who will introduce that our
esteemed speaker today thanks charissa
I'd like to introduce our speaker today
associate professor Manny Banerjee he's
a professor in the mechanical
engineering and design group a good
friend originally trained as an
architect banning holds a graduate
degrees in architecture mechanical
engineering and design so he in one body
sort of embodies one of our principles
of radical collaboration across multiple
disciplines in his early career in India
he worked in the fields of architecture
structural engineering and built adobe
housing for the rural poor after coming
to the u.s. he worked in the field of
computer simulation software engineering
and product design his instruments is
interests in the confluence between the
digital and physical experiences took
him to Xerox PARC one of the famous
research labs here in the valley where
he worked on ambient media and physical
computing he was also a designer at IDEO
for about 10 years as a design
strategist creating novel experiences
and crafting futures for high technology
companies and in addition to all of this
research he does in technology and
design theory he is also a technology
artist who has a major commission
installed now in the San Jose
International Airport you should
definitely take a chance to see that if
you are coming through the airport and
but the thing about banning is he's
happiest when he's in the presence of
sharp minds sharp cutting tools wood
dust cutting oil and the smell of solder
he's a real builder so I'd like to
introduce
professor of energy and he's going to
talk about design thinking and how you
make design thinking strategic good
morning everyone
it's great to see so many people
attending I'll speak a little bit about
this notion of design thinking and how
it is come to be used as a strategic
tool in a very many different in very
many different regimes and different
contexts but before I do that I'd like
to set a larger kind of a backdrop to
frame my my my arguments and if you look
at some of the larger mega trends that
are going on in the world today we I
think are poised at a very very
interesting moment in the history of our
civilization and that has profound
questions that are brought to our
organizations and even our roles are and
it's no longer something that one can
ignore in the in the course of one's
daily daily work so just to look at the
mega trends we have very fragile global
economies a very highly rate of
unemployment a lot of shifts in
economies and even in in the global the
major players we have seen some big
shifts in the in Europe we we have very
large issues such as very uncertain and
energy futures the price of the bio
barrel of oil is going to shift and I
was just at a talk by the head of shelf
the CEO shell and he said that the one
thing that we know for sure is that the
barrel of oil is not going to the the
price of the barrel of oil is not going
to come down we're we've emerged into an
extremely connected global system and
there are there are feedback loops that
exist today that did not used to exist
before and we have a global instability
at the level of political shifts and a
lot of geopolitical shifts that are are
connected to very necessary resources
that we that our civilization is built
on
we as far as business is concerned we
have all seen extremely radical shifts
in the entire way in which our markets
are playing out with completely new
players and technology regimes changing
the rules of the game and then we have
other things that we are used to
thinking of as being far away on the
horizon such as climate change and the
environment a crisis and the new
sensibility is among the gen y and the
gen Z populations but these changes I
would argue are no longer dis on the
distant horizon but actually influencing
changes in the tectonic plate that we
are standing on so given this kind of a
mega trend what we are looking at is a
very very dynamic and uncertain future
the only thing that we can be absolutely
sure about is that we are going to be
faced with having to deal with a lot of
changes and in this in this backdrop of
a very very dynamic future what we see
is that innovation is being seen by
leaders as opposed to all the other
normative tools as a way to build a very
new capacity a new capacity for agility
and resilience in the face of this kind
of a dynamic future because the rules of
the game are changing all the ways in
which one has gained one's market
dominance are no longer the guarantee
for maintaining it and so there is a new
kind of capacity building that needs to
happen and it's being recognized now if
we look at this in this slide it's a two
by two kind of matrix where we have on
the x-axis we have existing contexts and
new contexts and on the y-axis we have
existing solution the new solution it's
a very simple 2x2 button I think it's
quite profound where if you happen to be
in a market where you are offering the
same kind of solutions that you were
offering before and the same people in
that case you're probably you fortunate
enough to be very secure
and the ROI on innovation is very low
you should probably not spend any time
on on money on being particularly
innovative if you were that lucky but if
either of the two change then there is a
there is a need to be very innovative
about how you're going to approach a new
context with the existing capabilities
or offerings or how are you going to
create new solutions that are successful
are in the existing context but if both
of them change then all bets are off and
and what you've done in the past is not
necessarily the litmus test for what's
going to happen in the future and what's
going to make you successful and what
you what got you here is not necessarily
what is what's going to get you there
and that's a very different regime and
that's where you need very revolutionary
and different kinds of ideas where the
success metrics are are are shaped very
differently and if you look at this
matrix one would like and and put
yourself in a in a mindset as to where
do we belong I would argue that given
how dynamic the future is we actually
belong to the top right quadrant all of
us whether we like it or not are
actually because we are entering a very
uncertain regime marked by a lot of
potential turbulence also have the
capacity to deal with with completely
new solution the new context so with
that in mind what the question is what
are the kind of processes that we need
in order to generate the kind of
thinking and the processes and and and
the outcomes that we want out there so
in this slide we have a truth table
where we have essentially what we are
looking at is do we know what the
outcome we want is and do we know what
the process is that will get us there
and we have depending on whether each
either of them unknown you get four
different quadrants and on the top on
the right you have this quadrant called
paint-by-numbers that's where you know
the outcome
and you know the process and pin by
numbers refers to the children's you
know game where you join the dots and
the numbered and the picture of the line
emerges or the clown emerges and you
don't really need to know what what you
know you all you need to know is what
the next point is crest on the top is
where you know what the outcome is you
don't know the processes and and you
could be looking for a long time in a
hit in this way in order to get to the
outcome
now fog is a type of project where you
don't know either and you really don't
know what you bought what you want and
you don't know what how to get there now
it turns out that in the extremely
complex world that we're playing in in
reality I think it is judicious to
actually recognize that that a lot of
the challenges that we think up in by
numbers are or we know how to get there
are in reality foggy projects and in
foggy projects it is entirely
appropriate at a given point to not know
what the outcome is
but then what one needs to do is turn it
into a movie project where you bring in
a very robust process that will call
which which will give you a sense of
what the outcome might be and lead you
to the outcomes so you don't have 20/20
vision looking forward but you embark on
a journey that will get you there and
that's that's called a movie project and
in reference to the movie industry that
has very many different players coming
together to make make a make of a
complex experience with very large
budgets and and and even though there
are very many different kinds of movies
that I made the roles and the processes
of make what could what it takes to make
a movie as well understood and the
process is is used over and over so in
terms of the process we have out here a
process that has emerged out of the
design industry but now it has it's been
used in a very powerful manner for all
sorts of strategic purposes
Hamilton it's an approach that that does
two things very well it frames problems
creatively and then generates the
innovative solutions on the other side
so design thinking is is works both on
the problem side of the equation and the
solution side of the equation and it
tries to outperform normative technique
and combines it's combinatorial in the
sense that can be used alongside
normative the normal normal techniques
that we use but it size to outperform
normative techniques with with a it's a
structured use of creativity so you see
new solutions new strategies completely
new types of systems and paradigms at
the add and and the other thing that I'm
going to go into is that it operates at
the nexus of domains but what is also
very interesting right now as we see it
is that it's beginning to form a new
kind of leadership or it is if you look
at some of the leaders we hold in high
esteem and and try to characterize what
it is that that makes them so special
and then you look at whether our top MBA
schools are actually instilling exactly
those attributes into that and we find
that no it's actually it's a different
kind of thinking and it so happens that
a lot of the more innovative leaders out
there who are in the business of
creating completely new markets not just
capture markets but to grow market and
and to create large strategic visions
that are changing entire behaviors or
off of people in larger systems these
people are not just using deductive
thinking or or inductive thinking they
are using other kinds of cognitive
modalities that are embedded in in
design thinking and and if you look at
where these distinction has come it's it
you know about 12 or 15 years ago our it
by a large set of factors leading up to
it it became increasingly clear that
that the community of people who where
designing new experiences or new new
gadgets and so on
we're actually exhibiting a very
different kind of thinking and with as
unique to that community as say
businesses to physics and physics is to
sociology to the very different style of
thinking but that thinking has been
formalized there's a lot of thinking
about what how it can be embedded into
processes and how those cognitive modes
can be it can be shared and learned and
it's been used in very strategic ways
it's been used to create completely new
experiences very different kinds of
systems new strategies at every level
from from technology strategy to
corporate strategy to to R&D strategy
interventions in very complex spaces
where where societal issues collide with
technology upwellings colliding with
regulatory issues with market issues
with new products and services and also
creating new visions for the future
where we're interesting and very
compelling future visions of our futures
that might be not too far away but then
using a strategy of
ask figuring out what your next step is
in terms of those visions now design
unlike a whole lot of other fields is
very has very open boundaries and tends
to play up the Nexus of very many
different domains so at the very very
basic level its plays of the Nexus of
business issues technology issues and
human issues and that's where it does
very well but it's set in the backdrop
of larger issues such as the social
cultural economic trends and and the
larger backdrops and the source of the
play now the other thing that emerges
out of this that's predicated out of
this extremely you know conjoint space
and what is definitely coming out to be
a very very powerful issue and to is
this ability to co-create so instead of
instead of like-minded people sitting
together
and and you have let's say a roomful of
engineer thinking engineering thoughts
what is what is proving to be a very
powerful tool is to get diverse agents
that come together and they transcend
their disciplinary boundaries or
organizational roles in order to see
completely new possibilities that lie
outside of that typical boundary
condition then create new ecosystems or
new markets or platforms and behaviors
that are a combinatorial and what we're
finding is that and this this notion
that is gaining ground and it's being
adopted by a lot a lot of companies have
is is actually gaining traction into
expanding the canvas on which we are
painting in terms of larger changes
larger transformation and this is
particularly important as we emerge out
of an experience economy and enter a
transformation economy so if you look at
what design thinking is about it's
actually innovating both on the problem
side of the equation and also innovating
on the solution side of the equation and
unlike a lot of other processes very
sequential where you figure out what the
problem is and then you go off and solve
it our style is is somewhat different ah
and we actually go back and forth
between the problem domain and the
solution domain and the act of trying to
solve a problem in you know in a
prototypical way is actually another of
a terrific probe into what constitutes
the problem domain and it gives you a
lot more understanding into new
dimensions and nuanced aspects of the
problem domain and we have our own ways
of eliminating risk in this way without
compromising the degree to which an idea
can be radical because right now most of
our thinking is so risk-averse that that
that aversion to risk also drops the
ceiling on what is what is considered
possible or feasible and and essentially
we are locked into ways of thinking that
that generate only incremental
thinking and so this is a structured way
in which to keep alive the possibilities
of doing very out-of-the-way
out-of-the-box thinking but meanwhile
finding much better ways of of risk
mitigation and if you look at the larger
system as a whole arm what is what we
are doing is we are actually trying to
make changes at both as an internal
level and at the external level and this
is a this in a sense this is a fractal
in nature one could be talking about a
very large organization or a regional
issue or one could be dealing with with
the individual and the person and and
and so this two by two is is looking at
on the x-axis you have on one hand
internal changes on the other hand
external changes but on the y-axis what
you have is is the the problem side of
the equation which is problem framing
and definition and and then how do you
solve the problem the problem solving
any quick execution so the distinction
between what to do and how to do and so
our processes are one that that allows
you to very very carefully understand
but also creatively understand and
identify what is the real challenge what
is the nature of the real challenge go
down to more causal pathways and unlock
potentials and unlock opportunities that
can be leveraged in very very new ways
in very economical ways and way elegant
way is to come up with very very
leveraged solutions and and which are
deeply human centered so that so that
the human side of the equation which is
a very complex and very powerful part of
the equation is not overlooked but in
doing that you understand you understand
very many new dimensions of the problem
itself that allows you to come back and
pin the problem in in a new way so this
is our processes are you know built
around around these frameworks
and what it also does is takes a large
group of people and a team in a complex
team at different point of view and
phase matches them in terms of what
semantic mode they're in so that when
someone is being generative that
everybody's being generative and once
when you're being evaluated everybody's
being evaluated so instead of a lot of
destructive interference and the energy
you get very efficient solution very
quickly and then of course what it
really the larger implications are is
that our culture if the world that our
civilization is to a large extent
predicated by by the nature of our
institutions and an organization and
even though as people we can be
brilliant and we can be extremely
creative especially when we're at home
and and thinking about water you know
fun party we can create a cetera we are
all very creative people we tend not to
bring that creativity to our workplaces
and that's because we're conditioned to
not be particularly creative we have the
organization's are very good at reading
out innovation in a very very you know
systematic way and it's the the unusual
organization that really has innovation
deep into it in as a cultural value so a
lot of what we talk about is also how
you can some organizations and we you
know we've done a lot of work with
organizations with you know this is
something that we've been dealing with
three years and a lot this is this is an
issue that we speak about a lot and
there are some techniques and strategies
around this as well so in kind of
pulling out in and synopsize in what we
design thinking is and and why it's a
strategic tool first of all design
thinking represents various and way of
operating um it is it is and it's not
exclusive in the sense that it's not you
don't have to have a designer label in
order to be able to do it it's actually
very simple in some senses but difficult
because it's it also is it it takes a
certain level of openness and
and and and it's a little bit like
learning a sport where where you
actually have to do it to get good at it
uh but it there's no doubt that it has
what we are finding it has that it has a
tremendous strategic value because a lot
of the big decisions that that where the
the ramifications could be could swing
it from one way to the other can be
address with these tools and and one of
the biggest things that it does in my
mind especially because we are in the
world which is surfeit with people who
know who have the skills to solve the
problem but relatively short of people
who know how to frame the right problem
these are tools that are data that are
good for being very incisive word
problem framing and then in and and
because we are looking at these
extremely complex problems that fall
into the what we call wicked problems as
is defined by hospital
we have approaches to deal with these
calm very complex and fuzzy issues and
then of course creating the will the
vision that leads to creating the
creative roadmap which is to not not
have the potential for leverage change
be lost along the way or be killed by
last mile problems but combining that
high-level view with with how do you
make it tangible and and realizable and
finally get to the outcomes that one
once we I spoke about the culture of
innovation and ultimately for all of you
who are some live with what blue ocean
strategies are this this notion where
instead of fighting the red ocean which
is red with the blood of you know where
all the sharks are circling for the same
same food and where the name of the game
is better marketing or better pricing
but diminishing returns on the bottom
line how can you use these tools to
create blue blue ocean strategies where
you come up with a completely new market
for that for a while there are a few
competitors ifs and and you you've
outpaced competition
with whatever meager resources that are
available because resources are always
Rigo compared to the large changes one
could be making so with that I'm going
to throw it back to Bill and invite
questions actually Thank You Danny I'm
going to step in for a moment I have a
few words I'd like to say and also give
folks some time we have a couple of
questions in the queue already and Bill
will be facilitating a
question-and-answer session at the end
of my comments here so let me just
slides up and so first them I just want
to introduce the Stanford center for
professional development we've been
delivering education to industry for
over 40 years and so we have reasonable
experience creating these educational
programs to address the career-long
learning needs of professionals and
managers and executives in industry at
Stanford we're really pleased to be
offering the Innovation Master Series in
partnership with faculty like Bill and
Bonnie and for three days a senior
faculty will lead you to your hands-on
workshops where you can learn the
problem-solving tools and problem
finding frameworks that lead to
innovation and strategic leadership that
have been pioneered by the Design Group
and the d.school at Stanford we created
the program really for managers business
leaders and decision-makers who have
been faced with this daunting task of
retooling and revitalizing their
enterprises so here you can get a sense
of who might benefit from attending in
addition we created the program because
for quite some time we've been hearing
about how organizations are struggling
to make innovation routine in today's
business environment companies continue
to be challenged to implement more
projects with fewer resources and here
you can see some of the key takeaways
that can help you navigate these
business challenges to impact the long
and success of your organization one of
the most unique aspects about this
program which is quite different from
the other programs that we do at the
Stanford center for professional
development is that you really get an
opportunity to engage with the students
who line up of faculty from the Stanford
design group in the d.school they've
pioneered design thinking to solve those
wicked problems that you heard about
from Danny and so they and you know
what's quite unique is that all the
faculty are very engaged and participate
throughout the workshop so now I'd like
to just take a moment to get your
feedback that we really appreciate sort
of what's your level of interest in the
innovation master series as you heard
about it just appreciate that the
feedback and will hang on for just a few
moments here so we can get some
responses in and then I see that there
are quite a number of questions that
have come in and so while you're
responding to that pool I'd like to turn
it back over to Bill who will facilitate
our QA Thank You charissa you know that
I'd actually like to start with a couple
of questions for for banning because
there's so much information packed in
almost every one of these slides I'd
like to unpack it a little bit if and
what I'll do is here is maybe go back to
one of the diagrams the very first
diagram that talked about this
two-by-two or you've got you've got new
solutions existing solutions existing
context new contexts and maybe that just
make this very contemporary let's let's
take an example that unfortunately was
just in the paper this morning
yeah the yahoo organization announced
that they're downsizing by almost 20%
they're going to have to unfortunately
have 2000 people and you know the press
reports on Yahoo of course have been
that this is a company that's lost its
ways from the early innovators in the in
the business
of the web and the internet and you know
and it's no longer relevant which is
fascinating because it's only 12 years
old you know what it took
General Motors hundred years to become
irrelevant and then to rebuild itself
and yahoo has only been around you know
for a little over a decade and yet
here's a company that has 700 million
users makes four and a half billion
dollars in income a year and a billion
dollars in profit by most measures that
would be considered a phenomenally
successful company and yet I think as
you point out we're in this era of chaos
and rapid change and incredibly you know
difficult competitive environment and
you know I've seen you we've done some
work with Yahoo we know the people there
very well and they're super smart folks
and they're working really hard on
solving this problem but what we've seen
them come out with are at best
incremental solutions a few new features
on Yahoo and there's a few new features
on Yahoo Finance and a few evolutionary
things they're flipbook product which is
a sort of news aggregator is a pretty
interesting product but clearly they've
emerged into an environment where
they're in a completely new context with
Facebook that well first for google
dominating search and Facebook
dominating social and not having a
mobile platform and mobile being the you
know the dominant new method of inner of
intersecting the internet so I'm curious
Danny you know if you were to say you
know what do you think Yahoo should do
or where should they be in this diagram
what your advice would be you can see I
think it it can be addressed very many
different levels but with any company
that that is playing in this space are
first and foremost apart from the b2b
aspects it's very deeply human issue the
interface between between a large system
such as Yahoo an array connected face
and the and and the
the layer that connects that system to
the human is a very very complex layer
and if you look at what they're doing
there they started out with with a
paradigm that got them us to a certain
place very very quickly and then the
ground shifted from under them and so
right now a lot of the innovation that
they have made are within a frame that
that has that that in itself has a lot
of Merit but it's been keep up keep keep
pace with with what the future was
coming was bringing to them and moreover
they did not take charge of the future
there if they so as a management process
they were left with managing the present
rather than creating the future and so
in that sense it's in in abstract terms
are what instead of trying to squeeze
out value out of a frame that may or may
not be completely in tune where the
future is going are one would what would
be warranted is is a real revisiting of
new friends and new products and given
that the space one is in where one
doesn't have to metal in and roll out
new new and internal combustion engines
or some such thing one can move very
quickly and if you look at what Apple is
done or Google is done it's it's you
know one can see that even though these
are very giant companies in this space
one can also move quickly you know I
agree I think the fundamental thing that
Yahoo faces in many companies face to
come you know talk to us at Stanford who
do projects with us where comes the
Master Series is that somewhere along
the line the paradigm they were working
in has completely shifted and the things
that they used to do no longer work
which which brings us to this there's
another diagram here that I think is
really kind of critical to unpack and
it's this notion of problem framing
versus problem solving what I see and I
think you might might have some comments
on as well is that the big the big idea
inside Design Thinking isn't so much
that the problem-solving tools are
better sure we use you know an advanced
form of brainstorming and biomimicry and
other forms of unpacking problems and
coming up with new solutions but it
seems to me that the big leverage for a
company like Yahoo or Apple when it was
redefining itself you know as a media
company or General Motors in the in the
auto industry in general in the US has
its redefined its connections to the
consumer it really comes from problem
finding but that you you have to keep
looking to see where the ground has
shifted can you talk a little bit about
this problem finding process some stuff
we do with ethnography of need finding
because I think that's that's critical
for people to understand and Design
Thinking isn't just a new way of solving
problems that actually it's any way of
finding what the real problem is um so
given that a lot of these offerings come
from the conditioning that that that
either a standard business offering
given a market rising or or what the
median wants for them what a mean the
market survey results might phone or
water technology is capable of doing
those are often what shaped business
decisions or technology decisions but
what our way involves a few things one
of them is you saying that actually for
a product or a service to be really
really successful they need to be driven
by a very deep insight about unmet needs
that that customers or potential users
in the future are not able to express
right now because those systems don't
exist right now
so I are
which to understand what what we ought
to serve our customers with is currently
is very good for validation but it's not
good for figuring out what to do in the
first place those need to be a lot
richer and so the tools for validation
can be kind of garbage in garbage out
kind of systems when it comes to being
in finding the right motivations that
that you need to under
so we steal a lot of the processes from
the world of cultural anthropology and
we have reuse @na graffiti tools to to
to go into the lives of people and
understand what is happening in their
mind what are the mental models what are
their motivational frames what are the
phenomena at play which they don't know
how to express to us but our tools are
are can can given what we can observe up
their actions and given what they can
say which is observable our tools are
able to leap beyond that level that they
don't know how to express and get into
that part of the the iceberg that is
under the surface to unpack what's
really happening in water and among them
water absolutely tremendous potentials
and opportunities out there but also
design levers and design principles that
would make a difference between a very
technically sound solution versus a
runaway success because it was that much
more insightful and that is at the level
of the the human aspect and then there
is also something that we do which is
that we take a very very large systems
point of view and because we don't like
to make these disciplinary distinctions
we are actually very common
toriel in the way we look at things we
can actually overlay social issues in
our futures way of looking at things and
and combine long term thinking which out
term thinking and take a very nuanced
view of how the system
and much like an architect uses tracing
paper to overlay different systems and
then propose very very carefully but
also very insightful strategies that
would change the game um thanks that's I
I think I understand where you're going
with that um I'm looking at the
questions that have come in and there's
quite a few because I think it's an
interesting topic let me give you a sort
of a combination of two or three of them
there's a lot of questions because
obviously Design Thinking involves
innovation innovation involves people
being creative there's a lot of
questions around creativity what advice
can you offer to make Design Thinking
more accessible to people who are
struggling to be creative someone
mentions the gardener who's a social
scientist lists imagination under
spatial intelligence as imagination
something that can be improved
systematically is there a way to measure
it and you mentioned you know you
mentioned that people tend to not be
creative in the workplace are there
given that our as engineers our job is
to come up with solutions do you think
there's some reasons that cause us not
to be creative are there something in
corporate environments to dampen
creativity so people seem to be very
curious about this issue of creativity
and enhancing it or or teaching it and
what happens in a corporate environment
that tends to dampen creativity that was
a lot of questions so okay so first and
foremost I think that we've been said
this huge lie from the time we were
River children that either you're born
creatives or you're born on creatives
and we you know we get brought up saying
oh that person is going to be creative
because look how well they draw and here
this person is going to be a math major
because they're they're very serious and
they've you know they're they're very
structured in their thinking etcetera
turns out that there is no doubt that
there is difference in the levels of
creativity that people exhibit no it's
no different from from whether people
are are are athletic or not and not
everybody will make it to the Olympics
but we can all all we all learned how to
walk and so so
what we have in in the potential of a
certain part of our brain that we have
been conditioned to not not use in
certain kind of tasks and it at a
neurological level what is happening is
is most of our our modern-day thinking
and decision-making takes place in our
left prefrontal cortex and a lot of
decisions that are that are made relate
to to abduct deductive and deductive
thinking or inductive thinking which is
essentially posing a question and
proving it out and once you have the
answer that gives you a certain new view
of what the answer is an inductive
thinking is is a pattern matching kind
of a thing where if you see hundred
curls that are black you postulate that
all crows are black but but we have
other ways of thinking that we use on
day in in the daily life all the time
and that is those are called abductive
and reproductive thinking objective
thinking is is kind of the way a
detective might operate we're given very
few clues they ask questions about what
might have happened so you use the power
of your imagination
to wonder about in a probabilistic way
what might have might explain the few
and very inadequate clues that are out
there and then that forces a certain
kind of line of questioning that Dharma
that uncover some more clues now it so
happens that we are so mired and
conditioned in the world of deductive
thinking that in an organization you
have to defend your position in terms of
what can be proved or what can be model
or what can one can put numbers to
before it's done and and we all know
that it's not that that figures lie it's
more Liars later right in the sense that
you can make numbers do anything and in
some senses that's where a lot of our
creativity goes right in building the
arguments for things that can be
defensible but what there are so I think
in the in the organization we spend more
time worrying about the the all the the
narrow ways in which we define
how we mitigate risk because we
absolutely have to mitigate risk but we
take on a larger risk so to create
enclaves of where a new kind of process
is possible or a new kind of behavior is
possible and a new kind of thinking is
possible it is very important and so is
the question as to whether innovation
and innovative thinking and creativity
can be learned absolutely it can be it's
not question of of you've been learning
it's actually a question of unlocking
it's a question of turning the key and
finding it and then of course there is a
there's a it's a matter of like
everything else one has to practice it
and bring it into very close to one's
life and there are all these these you
know ways in which one can become a
whole lot better than one is and and I
think one of the profound things is that
it is not just it doesn't just have to
do with one's business decisions it's a
it's also very very useful in our lives
it's because every question one can one
can deal with in a creative way one gets
into a habit of it um actually and just
as a matter of fact to give you some
resources on that because we certainly
believe that creativity can be unlocked
can be taught can be enhanced
imagination can be enhanced one of our
one of our professors in our MSN a
department is just just published a book
called ingenious a crash course on
creativity Tina Selig is the author and
she's a fantastic teacher in her new
book is coming out just this month and a
book that we've been using for years
that we actually use in the master
series as well comes from one of one of
our older professors and now emeritus
James Adams who wrote a book called
conceptual blockbusting a guide to
better ideas
I'd recommend either of those as a first
start instead of trying to think about
how creativity works and how you can
unlock it in yourself
I have temporarily cut one or two more
questions there was a question from the
webinar audience what is the role of
government in this paradigm shift
it seems to be a big transformation and
business may need a push you know or
some assistance from government do you
have any any observations on either the
US or other countries that you've worked
with and how the government's can impact
this transformation towards an
innovation economy several governments
have taken on the initiative of having
national innovation policies because
it's not just looked at as something
that involves the corporation but it is
it is seen as something that is a
capacity-building tool for the for
entire nations Singapore has a hasn't a
national innovation policy there I'm in
conversation with multiple government
agencies looking at either national
level or or more more regional level or
Department level innovation policies I'm
actually in conversation with people in
you know in in the policymaking world
because because the tremendous play that
innovation can make in policy because if
you look at a mechanism that has
potentially a tremendous leverage to
change our futures it is the it's the
policy and the regulatory environment
but if you look at how policy gets made
and how it gets rolled out it's
extremely defensive is extremely
incremental and it's very risk-averse
and in doing so if one had all the time
in the world and and we went sitting on
top of very violent and very very
disruptive exponential changes that are
taking place right around us then it
would be okay to be to roll out policy
at the pace that we do but among a lot
of policy makers and and the world's
leaders is a huge concern about the
structural aspects of how quickly and
how incisively we can open up these
issues so I'm working with a lot of
policymakers as well in revamping how
policy gets made and there's a huge
place for innovation out there as well
so both of the level of the government's
encouraging innovation and and creating
the right environment for innovation
and funding innovation in very many
different ways including including
promoting it in education promoting it
in organizations and and being open to a
certain kind of risk-taking because
because it is our fear of failure that
can that can bring about failure in
larger ways and that takes an
environmental and mind shift change as
well so there's a very good question
there's a profound level of difference
one could make if one could actually get
government's to be even more interested
in innovation I guess the final question
and this is it's an interesting one so
I'll just pose it I don't know that
there's a right answer but one of my
favorite quotes comes from Alma computer
scientists visit Atari and Apple in many
places and his quote is the best way to
predict the future is to invent it so
here's a predict the future question do
you anticipate a future will there be a
single platform which will integrate all
the features of Google Twitter Facebook
and other social media in one
interactive interface no I don't and
that's because because that has been a
kind of a fetish for people in a very in
a world where competition is is is bill
deep into how we operate now if you look
at natural systems out there in the most
healthy ecosystems are in nature are
ones where there's a large diversity of
species very complex relationships
between them very symbiotic
relationships between them and in any
given ecological niche you have
competition you have predation and
competition but in a larger system there
are very very many different kinds of
relationships that exist in going
forward because the in in dealing with
finding resilience in dynamic systems
there is no doubt in our minds that and
in like it these theories are emerging
from very many different fields right
now and they all kind of matching
in terms of what constitutes resilience
in dynamic frames what the name of the
game is creating new ecosystems it's not
one single platform but it's networks of
networks that know how the coexistence
about each other well thank you so much
to both of you
really appreciate you taking the time
and I think we had a really great
webinar here today I noticed that there
are actually a ton of questions still in
the queue and I just want to show you
that we'll be sticking around to answer
those so just sit tight while we do that
I also want to just point out for the
innovation master series there is an
important deadline of April 11th there's
an early registration deadline there and
you can see some pricing details as well
so thank you again for joining us if we
do plan to make a video of this
presentation available and we will be
sending out an email announcement when
it's ready it will also be posted on the
SCPD You Tube channel which you can find
on our home page if you would like to
print out PDFs of today's presentation
please select the handouts icon locate
located in the top navigation bar and
click download and you can also print
the slides to PDF and there's a PDF icon
on the bottom of your screen thanks
again and hope to see you again soon
bye-bye